so we're speaking to you and we're
speaking to the nation and today we are
putting Jillian Keegan Secretary of
State for education on notice
in the last
in the last six days
319 serving teachers in schools in
England have voted to reject the
government's pay and funding offer
thank you
more
[Applause]
Morty just under six days more teachers
voted in that than in our first
preliminary ballot which lasted four
weeks
Jillian we need to say to you you are
not reading the room Neu members
any new members are telling you clearly
and in ever bigger numbers your offer
does not cut cut the mustard we are
telling you we can win a re-ballot on
this dispute as well
Jillian your any new members they're
telling you that your offer is
unacceptable
it does not deal with the acute shortage
of teachers in our schools shortages
that parents and pupils see every single
day
your offer is not fully funded your
offer does not match the pay awards for
teachers in Scotland and in Wales
Jillian why do you think teachers in
England are worth less than teachers in
Scotland and Wales
Julian we are saying to you you need to
make a better offer because this dispute
is not going away our members are
instructing us that we have to keep
going for the sake of their profession
and of the children they teach
so Jillian we are writing to you today
to tell you that we are calling further
strike action on the 27th of April and
the 2nd of May
but we also want to say to you Jillian
and we really really hope that you will
listen to this
those dates are more than three weeks
away
so Julian there is time for you to make
a new offer which can resolve this
dispute
we really want you to do this Jillian we
want you to make a new offer that is
fully funded which matches other Rises
which begins to deal with the crisis in
our schools and offer that our members
would be prepared to accept
because Jillian they are telling you in
the strongest possible terms that your
current offer is unacceptable
and we want to say something now to
parents
you have told us that you are supporting
your teachers that you want investment
now in your children's education and in
their schools
we want to say to parents that we don't
want to take strike action and we don't
want to cause disruption to exam
preparation
so we will be asking districts to make
local arrangements for year 11 and year
13 pupils so that they will be in school
being supported to prepare for their
exams
and we want to reach out to parents we
want to say to parents we want you to
help us put pressure on MPS to get the
government to resolve the dispute so we
are asking all parents please contact
your local MP ask them to intervene ask
them to make the case to Jillian Keegan
that she has to make a new offer to
resolve the dispute
Jillian you know where we are we can
talk today talk to us because we aren't
going away our members aren't going away
our campaign isn't going away we will
carry on demanding that you invest in
this generation of children their
schools and colleges and the people who
work in them and together we are going
to win